[Music]
hello everyone my name is nori and today
i'd like to go over some ways to
practice arpeggios that i find to be the
most effective in general an arpeggio is
a form of broken chord where the lines
are either ascending or descending in
the span of either an octave or more so
something like this
or
or something like this
[Music]
these are all arpeggios so the way i
would practice arpeggios is pretty
similar to the way i would practice any
other line formation but there are some
specifics the first and most common way
for me to practice these is to apply
rhythm and accents now i made a brief
practice notes video a couple months
back outlining the different concepts
behind rhythmic practicing so if you
want to check that out i'll include a
link so let me just go over a few
so for this example let's look at part
of chopin's opus 10 number one starting
from measure 29.
so in my opinion these measures are one
of the most difficult in this etude and
it's because the hand positions are very
awkward and they're spread out so here
are a few ways that we would apply
rhythm
[Music]
so
[Music]
you can also apply triplets
[Music]
and when we're doing this we can shift
where we're starting our dotted note
rhythm so that we can cover all the
bases
[Music]
we can also add emphasis to the notes
that we've been holding with accenting
and again we can get creative with the
types of rhythms and the groupings of
accents that we're using now there are a
few reasons why practicing with rhythms
and accents is very effective
the first reason is that it allows us to
pay attention to certain notes that are
somewhat neglected when we're just
playing it straight this allows us to
strengthen those fingers used to play
those notes because we're emphasizing
and exaggerating the use of those
fingers the second reason is specific to
rhythmic practicing because it allows us
to build up towards a faster tempo by
working on small groups and chunks of
notes and what we're doing is we're
playing these small groups of notes very
fast
another reason is somewhat of a casual
thought but it's still quite important
to me
and it's that practicing in this way
keeps things a little more interesting
because there's a lot of variety when
i'm repeating the same thing over and
over again there are different patterns
to apply different types of accents and
i can get creative with it so that to me
is important and i think it's worth
mentioning
so going back to this passage
[Music]
it's useful to organize these arpeggios
into different hand positions
so let's go through them one by one the
first one
now
unless you rock mod enough that whole
stretch
is not a hand position
so to me i would break it up into two
different ways so this leads to another
common way of practicing these which is
to block certain notes
so in this case i would block
or
[Music]
and i organize in this way just by the
natural positioning of the hands now
let's look at the next measure
so here
it's very awkward
i would use fingers five four two one
because
to stretch a fifth with fingers two and
three is a bit much
[Music]
i would organize this into e flat
e flat
[Music]
the next one
[Music]
for this one i would really only stick
with one way of organizing the notes
which is
c and e flat and a and e flat
[Music]
there's no use in trying to block these
wide cords which you would use 2 3 and 5
with
it's not really productive so i would
just stick with this
and of course we're practicing this in
this blocking style
[Music]
but as we're doing this we're getting
used to adjusting slightly between these
different groups
[Music]
and in that period of adjustment we're
also relaxed and we're able to find our
next grip
so the more we do this the faster we'll
be able to do this eventually and the
faster we'll be adjusting our hand
positions between
the different groups
so the next one also
[Music]
in that group and also
is reasonable here's another note
specific to this chord
but could be applied in other areas as
well so when we're going from
this position
to reach over to the d
if we don't move our elbows towards the
right
the d is quite a bit of a stretch from
the f and a flat
and that way
it's hard to be accurate again as a
reason to why organizing the hand
positions is important is that in this
case
if
the two different positions are very
clear to you
and in this case two notes are
overlapping
you know what to do with your elbow
and you're prepared to get these fingers
out of the way when we're playing the d
so the thing that we need to become
comfortable with is transitioning from
this position
to the next position
and in doing that it's basically two
motions scooping away from the keys and
towards the right to reach the d
because if we move just towards the
right this black key will get in the way
and if we just move away from the keys
we're not reaching the d so i know this
is basically common sense but it's very
useful to be aware of these very very
fundamental and obvious things
because when we're not thinking about it
sometimes we're not really sure why
we're missing certain notes or why
certain patterns are very difficult
so to just finish off the section with
this a major chord
in this particular instance i would
group it so that
this fourth is the anchor
[Music]
and in the pattern like this it really
applies to most of these chords
especially in this etude
the middle two notes are very often the
anchor points in this pattern so when
we're working on techniques such as
practicing arpeggios in this case it's
also a great opportunity to work on some
harmonic concepts at the same time
that's partially why and how i came up
with the exercises from my book of
modified chopin exercises where each one
takes you through a specific type of
technique as well as some harmonic
progressions scales and or modes if
you're interested in getting a copy i'll
include a link in the description
[Music]
i'm going to call this one
teeter-tottering before i used to call
this oscillating notes
basically i'm repeating groups of two
notes as i'm going up or down the
arpeggio
[Music]
so again like with practicing with
rhythms and accents we can get quite
creative with the types of patterns and
formations we're using with this type of
[Music]
teeter-tottering
[Music]
a great way to turn our ears and our
fingers to play more evenly is to start
off something like this with
a very exaggerated length of one of
these
teeter-totters
i find that in doing this it really
primes our fingers and our ears
to
be very sensitive to things being even
we can also choose to repeat certain
notes
[Music]
and again there are a ton of variations
to this we can choose to repeat every
other note or every group of three
so on and so forth
[Music]
so i hope you found those tips helpful
please subscribe if you haven't already
and i'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you